steve is with us steve's in new york
city hi steve how are you
hey dave and john thanks for taking my
call i appreciate it sure what's up
uh well recently retired about a year
now 53 years old
i have my work retirement but uh my mom
had passed away uh
18 months ago we sold her house and i
inherited a 150 000 that way
[Music]
now it's up to me to uh to invest it
through mutual funds
i'm not super duper comfortable with it
and i have some ideas but uh i don't i
don't know between regular mutual funds
tax deferred mutual funds
uh do i go all in with the 150 or do i
piecemeal it
and uh do you have any dad um
currently just my one son's college
she's a senior
how much do you owe on that uh
we probably owe another 35 000 for him
okay we need to set that aside right uh
yeah we have that and we have some
savings
okay and so there's no debt associated
with the college you just have an
obligation correct okay do you have a
home mortgage
uh not any longer no good for you good
for you
okay couple of things on investing um
let's start at the top
number one you don't invest in things
that you don't understand
never invest in things because some goob
on the radio like me said do it
or some goob on the internet that's even
worse said do it
okay so you understand it
the bible says in the multitude of
counsel there is safety and what that
means is you get some experts around you
to give you
advice and the advice is not that you
follow the expert the advice is so that
you
understand something you didn't
understand before so your financial
people need to have the heart of a
teacher
so that when you sit down with your
financial person and you get up and
leave you need to know something you
didn't know before you sit down
every time every time
i spent an hour and a half in my office
yesterday
with our chief digital officer
and three of our top uh senior
uh tech guys and they were trying to
teach me
oh jeez that's why you're in such a
great mood today
about a digital about our digital
platform
and i don't i do not have to be a
digital expert to be the ceo of this
digital company
but i do have to grasp the vernacular
and i do have to grasp
enough of it to help them to make wise
decisions under their help
so the multitude of counsel these
experts are in my office teaching me
about my company yesterday in this case
they're teaching you
about your money that you inherited from
your
the passing of your parent right and so
you're gonna gather that up you do not
have to have an mba in finance
in order to make easy financial
decisions basic investing decisions now
so rule number one is you don't do it
unless you understand it rule number two
is you put somebody in your life that
has the heart of a teacher
you can click smart vester pro at
daveramsey.com or smart investor
and find the person in your area we
recommend they don't work for us
um they pay us an endorsement fee and
they have to agree
to approach your investing the way that
we teach
and with the heart of a teacher i
personally invest steve inside my
retirement accounts
in four types of mutual funds growth
growth and income
aggressive growth and international
outside
of retirement accounts those funds all
create
taxes each year as they grow that's a
problem
there's two ways to avoid that with your
150
000 my preference is and the one that i
personally do is i
invest in mutual funds growth stock
mutual funds
that have what's called a low turnover
ratio now you ready for the teaching
part
okay here we go if you buy a rental
house
for 200 000 and it goes up in value to
300 000
and you still own it you do not owe
taxes on that 100 000 in growth because
you've not sold the house agreed
correct so you've got capital gains
growth
but you don't have any taxes because
you've not sold it
stock is the same way if a share of
stock goes from fifty dollars to seventy
dollars
you don't pay taxes on that twenty
dollar gain until you
sell it same is true inside a mutual
fund
the turnover ratio is when they sell the
stock
inside the mutual fund if it has a
ninety percent turnover ratio that means
almost all the stocks
get sold every year and so all those
gains are going to be taxable
every year if they have a five percent
if they have a five percent turnover
ratio which is a low turnover ratio
that means you're not going to pay taxes
on the increase in value
until you sell the mutual fund because
they aren't selling the stocks inside
the mutual funds hardly at all
much like that rental house or that
share of stock did that make sense
it definitely did so uh that low
turnover
what number am i looking at is it under
10 you want an under 10
turnover ratio under 10 percent yeah
because anything that turns over the
gain is they're going to send you a tax
bill on the gain
every year every every year yes okay so
you want it to not turn over hardly at
all
so that it only grows without taxes
until you sell it
now if you hold it a year when you sell
it you're going to be taxed at
capital gains rate 15 rather than
the ordinary income rate 30 40 percent
so the tax rate the tax rate is also
much lower for you
so it's tax efficient two different ways
one is you're not taxed till you sell it
and two is when you do sell it it's
taxed at a capital gains rate
your smartvestor pro can help you with
every bit of that
and finish teaching you what i did in
five minutes but that's the whole thing
all you gotta do is learn some basic
things like that they're not it's not
rocket science
you just gotta have somebody knows their
stuff and they show you how and then you
know your stuff
so you do it smart